the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night past
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media if you're watching this
show if you're listening to this show
thank you very much please hit that
subscribe button and if you gotta have
more then you gotta check out that
patreon it's five bucks a month it ain't
moving and staying there for the whole
year and if you sign up for a month you
get a uh excuse me if you sign up for a
year you get a month free all right you
get the Honeydew a day early you get it
ad free and you get it at no additional
cost and if you or someone you know has
a story has to be heard please submit it
to honeydewpodcast gmail.com all right
uh if you gotta have more than that then
you gotta check out the crab Feast man
the crab Feast goes back it's a seven
and a half year Library you listen to
two episodes a week it's still gonna
take you three years to get through the
damn thing all right go hit subscribe on
that it's audio only looking for a new
podcast go listen to my owl podcast the
crab feast all right [__] the crap fees
Five Stars that's the biz you all know
we do over here we highlight the low
lights and I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers I am
very excited to have this guest here on
the Honeydew first time please welcome
Byron Bowers welcome to the Honeydew
Byron powers
it's been a long time
coming what'd it do
shout out to honey doll thank you for
being here thank you for having me man
it's good yeah you look good I haven't
seen you for a while wow and I remember
your episode you had a great episode of
The Craft piece we were talking about
out there before and I wanted to talk to
you a little more about it but before we
get into it
um plug promote everything anything you
would like please at Byron bowels right
now you can catch me on Facebook uh that
was my Instagram but I do have a
Facebook and it's my name also
um and uh yeah that's pretty much it oh
top comedy special 22
Byron Bowers spiritual [__] or
spiritual n-word if you white or
spiritual
if you the KKK
uh and the spiritual inward as Daniel
Van Kirk would say
um it's on Hulu and it's on Disney shout
out BBK too yeah so
um yeah that's all I have for now yeah
follow my old [__] and follow my new
[__]
but you see your special we were talking
about uh before we recorded it deals
with suicide depression so I want to
talk about transformation right yeah all
these things but let's begin with where
are you from originally uh born in
Athens Georgia go dogs we number one
right now in the nation and
um I was raised in Atlanta uh Georgia
um shout out to Tokyo ATF who made this
video black on Comedy support black
owned companies even if you ain't black
you're gonna do it anyway through taxes
no PPP loans you know what I mean okay
um so yeah I was raised in uh Atlanta
Georgia so I went from a small town to
an even you know
compared to L.A a small City but it was
a big big city for Georgia big move from
Athens to Atlanta yeah yeah and your mom
and dad together at the time how old are
you when you guys make that move I
remember being like I did it twice so I
did it like I was like around
five I think five or six years old and
they have brothers and sisters I have a
sister also uh shout out to Japonica
what's her name japronica Japonica
Japonica that is the name I have never
heard have you ever met another Japonica
well Japonica is a flower Japonica
Japonica is a flower okay a Japanese
flower and a flower that they have in
the Middle East but they spelled it
wrong nah yeah they spelled it wrong on
the
birthplace it was so I was saying it
right yeah yeah I was pronouncing her
name proper but the flower yeah
so but no it is uh it is her name and uh
it's not too many of them because of
that that type of
she said she found some other ones and
she was mad she was like ain't no way
they copying they copying her because
they're younger
I'm like you searched the whole
Instagram and she's like basically
so uh okay so yeah you have two separate
fathers okay right
um that's how abundance works you know
sometimes the Lord blesses you with a
woman with multiple uh fathers
um so she's the light-skinned child I'm
the dark skinned child and if we ever
got confused by like which father was
present we would do the hand test no no
okay we didn't do that but you know it's
an old bit I wrote like this that my dad
that's your dad
but her dad died both our dad is dead
now yeah all right so shout out to you
jumping way ahead I don't know who you
shout out to but
um
tell me about it when you say something
[__] up you're trying to make it
better but you know
tell me about your dad
oh shoot my dad uh
as far as what I think tell me about him
what do you know about him man I've
realized when he died I don't really
know too much about him no I'm like what
his favorite color
don't know what his favorite food
you know you have those thoughts like so
when your parents they split them when
you're you're saying you went to Atlanta
you were with your just your mom yeah
okay so they they never did he come
around at all did you yeah I spent time
with them and uh for my memory was some
of the best moments of mine tell me
about my life what stands out what do
you see in your mind still I still see
like him coming to pick me up uh you
know some of the hugs because like my
mom's side we didn't really hug
and the meals like my grandmother like
cooking like you know they grew food in
the yard and all the food came from the
yard like the eggs uh we had chickens in
the back we had hunting dogs
um we would go fishing every Saturday
catch the fish fry the fish right there
on the spot
the rest went to the neighbors
um wine came from the wines the
muscadized uh Vine
corn was shook peas was shook uh
cantaloupe watermelon you know it's like
yeah honey honeydew you know but it's
it's like you realize me older like oh
this is what this is like abundance and
you know
um
you know life was like everything you
needed was provided like we want a snack
you go outside pick up two pecans with
your hands snap them bow you eating you
sitting down with family like it was
just a very like peaceful time
um
and then um
my dad worked for the power company he
would go to work every day uh very smart
dude had me in the YMCA and like all
these extracurricular activities
um we will hunt
um they put guns in our hands to teach
us to feed ourselves you know
at that age you just learned how to do
uh air rifles oh so he's just learning
you're training himself how to shoot
cans right and then we would fish also
uh remember going out on the boat
staying out overnight fishing and just
catching a bunch of catfish and brim
Southern like you know freshwater fish
uh it definitely was a more Simple Life
uh
and the Christmas was good and it was
just warm I just remember
um
and then like I ended up moving to
Atlanta and they were just like all the
normalcy just went it just changed
because now with my mother like you
don't realize you're older like these
people like 22 yeah you know like 25
you're like damn yeah and uh my mom was
a young mom just moved to the city you
know good looking lady
and life was just like with two young
young kids you know
um
trying to survive and that came with its
struggles and you would bounce around
from place to place and I'll be at
Bronner Brothers you know which is like
this Brahma Brothers is a black owned
hair company and they had a school my
mom went to this this hair school and we
would be there as kids just I remember
being on the chair just spinning around
and you know getting she hit me with a
brush One Time Boom stop stop spinning
around you know so
um
it was just a different
life you know
um and I think my first
Depression was around that time like six
and seven really yeah what are you
feeling just the Polar Opposites of like
are you longing to get back to what Dad
and I just could tell his family as well
like your grandparents on that side as
well yeah yeah
um I could just because only in their
40s or 50s you know that's still young
yeah you know what I mean yeah and and I
didn't I can't tell exactly what it was
I just know when I saw I just just felt
something wasn't right and I remember
seeing a picture of myself and I just
looked down at one one time you know
um it was just a different just the
position
and then I had to go back because
DFCS Department of Family and Children
Services got involved at one point with
your mom or your dad with my mom so we
had to go back and I went back to live
with my grandmother
for a while and then when that happens
does your sister go go and live that so
now you two are separated me and my
sister separated my sister so you're
losing your mom and your sister yeah my
sister goes to stay with my uh aunt
and my uncle you know R.I.P to my auntie
uh
and they had like uh two daughters
and my aunt was a teacher and my uncle
was a truck driver
so she went to a stable home
to live
and then I went to stay with my
grandmother
and this is your dad's mom my mom's
mom's mama okay the person my mom
probably thinks doesn't love her
and that's where you're going and that's
where I'm going the real brute like
strict
I remember being in bed in The Cosby
Show coming on you know
um at the eight o'clock yeah yeah yeah
that's not late you only drink milk you
don't like to drink milk this thick ass
milk came in this yellow carton like no
sodas no tea
um
switches you know
yard clothes come from yard sales
I remember having some big ass Pony
shoes I had to wear ponies yeah uh and
you couldn't get I mean the food was
like massive like
I mean big ass fries and big hot dogs
and like
soups and like still warm like food like
peanut butter came in a big ass can like
that you know I mean white because my
grandmother worked at the um in the
projects at the daycare center
so I didn't know at a time you getting
like that type of food you know
um
but Grandma had nine kids
come to find out and you don't know like
you talking about generational trauma
my dad mother and my dad parents were
together and had five
my mom's family was nine kids kind of
the project it's one of nine kids one of
the youngest of nine kids who father had
another family
so they getting raised by like uh like
Grandma probably was bitter and and so
your dad wait your grandfather your
mom's dad had nine kids with your mom's
mom
and another family how many [__] kids
do you have with that family
I never met him you know so you actually
have blood siblings that you have not
met yeah because you don't speak
it never spoke his name got it yeah
you know um
and
yeah it was a cold that was a cold place
you know
uh
yeah that's just what it was now when
you're living with your mom's mom at
that time is there anyone else in the
house with her or is it just a two oh
yeah of course this uh my cousin my like
two aunties that was there and I mean
Crowded House it's crowded and
everybody's young and like
you know is it it is loud and I will
have babysitters sometimes that's why I
learned how to walk home from school and
like
and you know in this this across the
street of the crossing guard and then I
would go the short away because I'm like
why would I go the long way when I can
go the shorter way and all these things
and like that's the place in my
grandma's back room where I got my dick
sucked by my babysitter you know what I
mean what how were you I'm like 10. you
were 10 how old was she probably like 13
or 15 you know and she sucked your dick
yeah and I [__] her a few times what
at 10 yeah but I knew what sex was how'd
you know what sex was because my dad's
my granddaddy on my dad's side has a
outside family also okay but
they uh and my dad and uncle young dudes
and my dad was in the Navy so
when we would go fishing oh we would
look at newly magazines
and I've seen my dad my dad had a nice
rotation of chicks
um and I picked this up that early too
huh yeah I think it's a part of the
thing like I remember looking out my
bedroom and it was a mirror on the
closet door and my I could see in my dad
room
and I seen them like kind of like [__] a
lady and he was like you know he wants
you to be gay
you know back in those days they would
do things he left the door open so you
could see him [__] yeah because in
his mind that wouldn't that for sure
would not make you gay look
I'm just trying to understand yeah I
mean that's one of the things I have it
correct that's one of the things I hear
you yeah I'm not judging I'm just I want
to make sure it's just a different time
that's a different mentality also like
well I don't know I don't know that's
the problem right of course you don't
you're 10. well I mean even now even now
I don't know what do you mean
well do you think that uh watching
heterosene no I mean sex no I mean like
overall that's what I mean by that
statement let me let me be more specific
when you talk uh
certain things
by uh a community
or a person and you grow up that way and
then you Branch out and learn
certain other things not just a gay
thing but like how money were all all
type of stuff
you start to question like other things
you would you learn and because my dad
was schizophrenic later on and we found
out that he might have been
schizophrenic
the whole time the whole time yeah my
existence is just like
a blur you know a part of it
okay so your dad's doing it's
questionable [__] yeah well now yeah you
know don't do that but
that is a mental issue that makes sense
why some things were done differently
than most people do them I have a
schizophrenia cousin and let me tell you
he does not operate like we operate but
now you have the question is it a
schizophrenic thing or is it a macho
thing like that's the questions you ask
it's probably all of that yeah it's
probably a jambalaya of that [__] a
potpourri of old ass like Macho [__]
schizophrenia yeah maybe religion thrown
in there you know what I mean it's a
whole mind we all church people you know
uh and Athens I think last time I
checked it was
the population is a hundred thousand and
it's a hundred Christian churches no is
that right like like yeah alone just a
hundred
um
but um
yeah man it was just a different
different existed like they're like
where hold on we we got off on the
tangent so the babysitter look man I do
shrooms so this is
it's okay that's the way this show goes
yeah
you needed people to be present during
the show
I do not want oh yeah so the babies are
sober yeah also you lost your virginity
at 10. yeah yeah yeah and then I had to
talk about to keep it a secret until who
was the babysitter was she a relative of
somebody was she a neighbor just a uh uh
like a friend of the family that was uh
watching me
um
and you remember I was telling my girl
and
she was like you molested and I did the
Joker house I'm a listing and she sucked
my dick and she was mad like like why
can't men say that they were molested
I'm like what are you talking about you
know what I mean we [__] we used to
look at a book I remember what the [__]
looked like
let's suck my dick how was I molested so
it was one of those
um
those things that you
don't understand affection until you
like
an adult
do you think you're molested do you
think that girl molested you that I
don't because when you hear other molest
stories you like listen I've sat here
listen to so many of them that's what
I'm saying here's what I want to say and
I don't want to downplay anything I do
know she said because my dad had a
reputation but they had a lot of women
she said I want you to do to me what
your dad do to them chicks and then she
put my dick in her mouth
and it was such a warm feeling
had a reputation my mom got seven
sisters
my dad had a book
of women of women
they he kept photos of him oh yeah he
killed photos oh he kept evidence yeah
was it evidence receipts I guess they
call them receipts yeah
what side you're on if you're looking at
that
if you're bragging it's received
laughs
[Music]
all right okay so Donna those are
receipts those girls uh this babysitter
this girl does this and you said she was
13. she had to be between 13 and 15.
I'll get gazed by the smell she's not 18
19. she's not an adult
I don't I I don't know I don't know if
that's molestation or if that's just two
young kids being curious yes
a young young woman
probably about to go in junior high or
whatever grade or just hormone it may
have had to be my raging hormones to
make those type of decisions
I mean it and from here for how it felt
you know what I mean 10 is Young
um I don't know I'm not an expert I
don't know what to do I think it is
there I would say 10 is is uh
is young but I'm I think my granddaddy
was nine or something
but this is a tradition in in the
community that we don't talk about yeah
yeah you know I mean 10 years old okay
so when's the next time you have sex was
it a while after that oh wow officially
probably like I think 18. okay in the
woods
in the woods okay basketball camp
yeah how'd you get away with that
just was on the basketball goal we was
on a basketball uh uh summer trip and we
was in I think Tennessee somewhere
and
my homeboy was just telling me what to
say to this chick and she was down and
she drove me in this uh this other guy
to the woods and
we went off in the woods and I remember
when he's about to [__] and she was like
we got to be careful
cause I've been caught the rest of a
[__] hit before
that she tells you that right before
yeah I've been arrested
and when those lips cracked open the
smell
the smell from that was so bad
I'll bet that when I finished
he's still because [__] ain't gonna
quit
until he buzzed ain't nothing nasty to
you bust you realize that okay uh my
when I got in the car my homeboy was
like don't touch me
um but when he uh Did You Know The
Simpsons were popular when we were
younger so when she said I've been
arrested for doing this before
all I heard in the wood through the
woods was like
uh Nelson's laughs but um
and then uh
funny story
we get back
and we get we show up late and Coach man
like what the [__] y'all was
like beetle beetle went and got some
[__]
coach what you did what
you're like
um he got some [__] look from who okay
you can't use some [__]
foreign
he's like this chick in the chick what
and we met a chick at the store the
chicken the white Honda
yeah yeah yeah
hey Colt
be the [__] the girl you trying to [__]
nah
and uh
he's like son
I'm gonna tell your mama
and I was scared he was like
she had AIDS nah oh man and my heart
dropped me and he was like I'm just
playing oh
oh my god dude I was nervous but also if
she had been arrested for [__] hair
she could have ate she very well
you taught one of them like roll over
like nights
the whole team giving you [__] uh shout
out to the shout out to the team
all right
um so 10 years old that happens you're
already uh
you're living at your grandmoms and was
and yes very strict living you said
you're going to church too are you like
are you not with that not with that
particular Grandma but it was just like
certain rules you know I mean
um
uh grandma was not
a person that smiled a lot you know uh
that I remembered
until I got older but um she's real she
was real strict and she was dealing with
you know whatever she was dealing with
which I didn't know at the time but I
was like damn Grandma me
um so
but
it definitely was like strong enough to
affect my mom in a certain way
and then what happens do you go back to
your mind I'm going back to my mom and
that's when how long how long are your
grandmoms I don't remember like a year
couple years probably a couple of years
yeah but that my sister know more than
me because at one point of time my mom
was sick my mom had a stroke
so I had to stay down there to while my
mom because my mom can talk on the side
of her face and she couldn't walk and
um and I remember like my mom like being
able to just move like a little part of
her mouth and I think I remember my
sister like like getting some slob off
her mouth the dancing [__] I ever seen
at the time you know and uh so I guess
they think I couldn't handle that and
you know my sister had to be there with
my mom and like you know bless her heart
but like help
you know help her with that stuff
and uh
you know it was tough but I went back
and we we ended up in Brandon Hills uh
apartments and that was just a wild ride
that's when you start getting into
sports and like being bullied and
um I mean I showed up and the guys were
sitting on the car and they was like
they pointed in my shoes and they was
like Daddy go right there I just got
some new shoes black with the little red
tips on it and they were like come over
here come over here and I went over
there and they was like [__] don't make
no Jordans
there was some stadiums there's some
Stadium shoes
and I didn't know that was the day I
found out what Jordan was because I
didn't know oh you had no idea I had no
idea you know I mean because my my mom
would make me with like church shoes and
like like I would dress country as a
little kid because my mom would dress me
up and stuff I guess she wanted to see
uh you know man where like fake snake
skin dress shoes and [__] like that you
know so
um
that's that's just me becoming a part of
of Atlanta living in Mountain Grove now
I had a reputation I moved to Mountain
Grove when I first got back to Atlanta
and I had a reputation being scared of
[__]
why because it was an incident to the
AIDS scare well me no this is this was
y'all I'm still young now like 11. you
know and me
uh my best friend at the time and this
other dude we all you know this was just
breaking empty apartments and doing all
type of fun stuff but it was this lady
over it was his chick she was she was
older she was like 15 16. and she came
over and they ran a train on her
and they was like you wanna you wanna I
never had
no one I know was had any childhood like
this what do you mean like nobody I
always had bad luck with trains anyway
uh I've never even been asked to be on a
train look not first middle last dollar
but it was weird for me because after
what I went through and they didn't know
seen a dude getting a girl and they like
pump it like you know I mean we like
kids like kids like
just doing all this [__] and then they
one day be like move need and push on
and he'll get in and do all that [__]
and they'll be like you want something
on I'm like nah and I was watching I
remember I was watching the uh Rocky
with the Russian dude Drago yeah Drago
in it and I'm watching it and this is
all going on in the background [__] and
then uh you know Eric shout out to Eric
was like hey you you scared of [__] and
when I walk around neighborhood be like
this nigga's got a [__] you know what I
mean
[Laughter]
mind you
we had the Booty Man
also what is that in Atlanta it was a
guy named Wayne Williams
who are we allowed to say his full name
yeah cause he was in he was in prison he
went to prison for murdering and raping
supposedly having sex with young black
man it was a black dude okay I didn't
know about this so Atlanta moving back
to Atlanta was a very
dangerous place so below all the
homophobia stuff was deep anyway because
you had this going on
oh and this guy was just out there
killing young black yeah so anytime
black gay men or young black men young
black gay men okay
um but but at the time you don't really
think about that you just know like oh
if you walked in the woods the booty man
might be in the woods you know what I
mean
um
and the reason I say that because the
apartment complex we lived there had
some Woods that led to the next
apartment complex now we end up moving
into the other apartment complex but I
didn't know this apartment complex
didn't get along with this apartment
complex on arrivals so
when I was when we all met up one day
they would just elbow on me like you
know you with them now
you know because we didn't have gangs so
to speak you could be like
two streets two streets or one side of
the street could be for the other side
of the street type stuff
um
and then I end up in his in his Brandon
Hill Condominiums which was huge
uh
and that's when like all my
skateboarding and stuff started when I
saw Tony Hawk for the first time yeah
and I was skateboard on these like we
had all these Hills and stuff and that
[__] was fun for a while
shout out to Tony Hawk sat right there
in that chair yeah
I met him I I didn't did I officially
meet him or whatever I was at the Oscars
last year and he was there oh yeah I was
like is that is that Tony Hawk and I was
like damn that's Tony Hawk that's good
dude but I never seen nothing like that
before so you said you mentioned first
time you were depressed was that five
six what happens when do you when do you
start really battling depression
and you don't really know what Suicidal
Thoughts you don't know what it is right
but I'm saying looking back now when do
you really start I don't know I mean I
got Cuts I remember cutting myself in
like either Junior High High School you
did try to commit suicide or you were
just cutting uh this was one cut I did
it one time I was like that [__] hurt
and uh
I was like I used a butter knife
yeah so I was so I was just doing this
[__] oh there's some of the butter knife
you know well good I'm glad you did not
a cut properly well if I were to use a
regular knife
because my girl got like bunch of skulls
her and her friend they got a bunch oh
really yeah and I was like because they
use proper knives
uh well you doing this for a while and
then it's like oh yeah no you forget
like you wanted to whatever it was I
know it worked because I don't remember
right without what was going on but I
mean you getting bullied like I'm trying
to play sports that wasn't working uh uh
you know pops on drugs
uh not fitting in
um
it was a lot you know
being being
broke you know um leaving the band
having you know I was in a band in fifth
grade and my mother always complaining
about the instrument I'm reading this
instrument you ain't even you don't even
play it a lot
it was a trumpet I was second chair in
trumpet
yeah that's something to brag about see
the best get first chair and then it
goes in the line like that you know I
was second chair it was only three
trumpet players
so
about default I was the second best
trumpet player but
I remember
um he's all these wind instruments and I
remember I made somebody laugh I knew I
could disrupt a whole band
and I waited till we was playing and I
did some [__] in the whole band just
started it just [__] up everything and
I remember the teacher was like
uh uh I either could tell your mom what
you're doing
or you could like
you know
stop and I just left I just left the
band
so tell me about how powerful ass
whoopers are tell me about your dad
passing away how was how were you when
he passed how old was I yeah wow I don't
know
that's when honey boy came out when did
he pass
like 2019 that's recent yeah what
happened
um
he was property wait you don't know how
old you were three years ago I don't
keep up with my age get the [__] out of
here right now I know I don't keep up
with my age you're full of [__] I don't
keep up my age uh get out of here yeah
my grandma don't know how she is how old
she is and my mom barely know how old
she is it's a tradition what's your
what's your range somewhere between what
and what how would you say you are beard
and no beard
right now I'll say I'm 25 to 60.
if you kidding me sleep sometimes I
definitely look like I'm like 60 years
old
oh you got a rage man I'll tell you yeah
I'm sorry your dad passing away man you
know it was crazy
um
I'm at this uh I was in a movie called
honey boy
and we doing this uh press run is that
the one that was shot in Baltimore no
this was uh this was shot in L.A with
Shia LaBeouf and like oh yeah everybody
right and
you know we doing like a Oscar campaign
ain't never been a partner of [__] like
this before in my life and um
you know we doing red carpets and all
type of [__] and we like exhausted this
is like a tour doing press you show up
you get outfits all this stuff and um we
landed we was tired
um man my girl we couldn't wait to come
home and we landed on LAX and I turned
on my phone and I got a message from my
cousin and uh he was like um hey man
they got your dad and Macon
um he cold it five times
um and they said they're not gonna bring
him back to uh to to resuscitate on the
more and I'm turning my girl like what
the hell is coded and I Google it and
it's like his heart stopped and I was
like oh [__] so
um
I called him and he told me uh
um that they all defend the driver to
the hospital now so me and my girl went
home uh eight
put repacked and we went down got right
back got right back on LAX you know and
you know how brutal that is
and we get to Georgia probably like
midnight or some [__] so you come off of
this Whirlwind press tour for Oscar
riding the high literally to turn your
phone on and get news to your father's
dying yep and I um I called the airport
I'm like yo we need one of them death
tickets
like somebody dying type [__]
whatever they call it yeah like
you know uh
you know we get one of them discounted
yeah
you know um
and if they've been like no like y'all
just saying it because he black
not just like uh but um
I mean I put on an all black hoodie
you know
um
and got down and it took us three
o'clock when we got there three o'clock
and I remember Walt this video somewhere
me walking through this hospital all
black hoodie and it looks crate Hood up
and everything and it just looks crazy
because I'm just at peace and I have to
accept
like
um
damn
like this is this is it this could be it
so anything I gotta say I gotta say it
now
and this probably goes back to what I
told on on crab feast
um it was one point I didn't see my dad
for seven years
and I was angry at him
and then I looked back over my childhood
and I realized like when I was with him
I had the best times and I like he I
realized he was a great father he just
had his mental illness and the drugs and
stuff took over
um and I wanted to tell them that in
person
so I went down flew down uh and drove to
Athens then me and my sister went to
visit my dad for the first time in like
seven years we just that gave me the
address and we showed up at his house
after uh eating dinner
um
I was excited to say I ain't even
finished my dinner with my aunt I had a
steak mashed potatoes I put it into gulp
uh box put it under the seat and I
remember driving to his house and
telling my sister like yo
back in
you know if anything happened I want you
to you know hit the gas get the [__]
yeah don't worry about me yeah so
like I'm prepping this like it's some
type of drug deal yeah cause he's
probably know what was me I'm paranoid I
don't know what he gonna do and I'm
already preparing him because I always
thought like this person can kill me too
even though that's my dad I'm like you
know
uh it's a thing when you from the hood
like the hood or whatever can bring you
down this is gonna be my downfall
so
we pull up and it's like the hood
hoodies of the hood looking places run
down and and it was like an old dude
outside with no shirt on and a skull cap
and that was him I was like damn he's
sitting outside and that's when I was
like back in and [__] we backed in
and we sitting in the car like right in
front of them and I'm looking at them
through the rearview mirror and my
sister's like damn he ain't gonna get
out the car and I was like oh yeah
that's right because I'm like thinking
we gonna go together you know I mean uh
I heard Dad yeah
I'm like damn yeah so I get out and then
he he say he see her and she get out the
car and he was like you know this is the
country like y'all come on in you know
what I mean she left the car running and
he said that he she was like [__] you
know I gotta cut the car off and he was
I hope y'all like white people because
John's here and when my sister [__] John
I don't know no jar and we went in and
it was Elton John playing on this little
stereo system remember those radios that
had like the five disc changes in them
yep he had a a box set of Elton John's
uh CDs and he was just playing the whole
box set so
we go in and it's like meat like all the
the appliances are unplugged
um because he don't trust the electric
electricity or nothing like that except
the radio and there's no lights on so
that all that is naturally lit and it's
a chair like you you're sitting and it's
a love seat over here so my sister go
for the chair right that's a smart thing
to do so it's a team got to sit around
nobody and she said that he like that's
my seat and she get up
man and I started laughing and I go sit
beside it he come sit across from us and
he start packing cigarettes and he's
like you want some you know you want a
cigarette now this is after a seven year
yeah this is after seven years and I was
like I don't smoke and he
he packs a cigarette and he takes it and
he light and he look at us like like an
interrogation Style
and he smokes and he he was like he
chewing the smoke and I'm like this [__]
is weird why are you
why are you chewing chewing the smoke
and um and I'm thinking it's like Pope
in the cigarettes or something whatever
the [__] uh and um
he started asking us these these
questions and I'm talking to him and
asking how he doing but the music's
still playing so he's basically like
yelling at each other and then uh this
is so eerily similar to my schizophrenic
cousin's place when I go up yeah and he
like um
he like uh he asked me about a person
like a honey doll you know that's why I
said 100 beginning hundred dollars are
another schizophrenic cousin be having a
family and I was like I've never seen
her before and he was like I'll show you
who she is he get up and leave then me
and my sister look at each other and at
that moment I realized I didn't plan I
didn't make a plan for the house
so I started to tell her look if he come
out with like a gun or some [__] yeah
you know he'd come out with a photo
album
and he's like she's in there and we look
and these photo albums and it's all the
best I mean I'm seeing life before crack
right so you see these photos especially
in Black communities and how it was
families and all these tight-knit units
and his family members I never seen
before then there's pictures of my mom
and my dad like at the prom at the high
school dances and [__] I've never seen
and like I'm getting like misty-eyed and
and my sister never seen these photos
either you know so she's like you got
any other photos of my mom he's like
yeah turn turn The Pit turn keep turning
and then she turns and it's just naked
women
and it's like oh
but we don't
and I'm grabbing a leg I'm doing a leg
like this right because I don't want him
to snap or no [__] like that and I don't
know if she's aware of how to how to act
in front of like crazy [__]
so she's asking like oh that's a nice
lady like where did you meet her and
he's like I'm in Hood Church you know
and he's just going through this whole
he know what he met
all these women down to the T he
remember their name and everything and
it's so crazy to listen to
somebody you think is a certain way
actually
their intelligence
and
um at one point we thought long story
short we thought
he's like you keep going you're gonna
see my favorite picture and I thought it
was gonna be a picture of my mom
and we got scared and we we turned and
it wasn't a picture of my mom it was a
picture of my dad
in the same position like the women was
all spread eagle on their back holding
their legs up and then my dad was in the
same position holding his dick with two
hands
and like oh
it's like weird because
it's my sister
looking at this [__] that's his favorite
picture by the way but it's my sister
looking at these women and I'm sitting
next to my sister like I know me and my
dad perversion
but now I got my sister here and then my
it's my dad holding his dick with two
hands and I gotta think like can I hold
my dick with two hands
like it's like
it's a moment of like damn did I get
because most dudes are taller than their
dad my dad's still taller than me by an
inch and I'm like damn did I get shorted
twice you know
and then we yeah like we all laughing
you know what I mean uh that's my
favorite picture I love about this video
and everybody happy and I I never seen
him so happy before honestly in that
picture the way he's smiling is joy and
um he could have been high on weed or
something but that kind of dick you
should be smiling I know right and um
and that's when I was like oh since the
tension is broke that's what I'm gonna
tell him
how proud you know how proud I am to be
a son and I was like Dad I got something
to tell you uh he just looked at me and
my sister
and he just started shaking his head and
I was like
um
I wanted to let you know
uh that I had these moments when I
thought you were bad but I realized you
know that you were a good
father this whole time and he was just
like
look at my sister and he was like man I
appreciate it but
I can't I can't [__] your sister and my
sister get up
like well that was his response to what
you said yeah he was like she was like
well good seeing again Mr Bowers and she
headed toward the door and um
I started to get up and um I was like
nah it ain't about I don't know what
that about I don't even know where that
[__] came from and he would start
shaking his head like he I can't believe
you turned out like this
you know after you know you you granted
from college and everything you and you
pimping and your own sister and then
that's when I like
start now I'm triggered so I'm getting
mad like no you don't hear what the [__]
I'm saying and I started to yell and
then I'm starting to cry cause it hit me
at that moment like oh [__] he never
gonna know how I feel about him
and then my sister ended up grabbing me
like come on let's go and we got in the
car and I just I just bawled yeah and I
was just spent and I remember reach
under my seat and grabbing the steak
with my hand and just eating it like
it's like like a caveman so fast forward
uh we in the hospital with my girl my
grandma how let me ask you this how long
from that moment to a hospital now how
many I want to say that's like gotta be
20 13 2014. so six six years yeah five
six years so
um
by this time I don't do mushrooms and
everything so I've learned to
communicate with them when he has his
episode now
uh so we get in the room and uh I show
up with this white lady but it is really
but to everybody else she's some white
lady
and she's there with me and isn't that
funny that she's Israeli but to them
she's is that wild to her that she's
considered a white lady I think she
understands being but the first time
you're like oh wait it's Wilding because
my friends co-switch when they're around
her
they'd be like yeah [__] what's up and
then she walk in the room and they're
like good to see you again get into all
corporate and [__] I'm like what the
[__] I'm like what the [__] you know
what I mean cause I still say [__]
around and everything and um they they
don't they're not aware they doing it
that's how crazy it is but you know
um
we end up playing
uh Elton John in the room but my
grandmother's not a fan of John so she
started playing gospel so it's two
different sounds blaring over but when I
walked in the room my dad like he opened
his eyes even after all that the
hospital he did yeah the hospital he
opened his eye he was he was he said he
coded five times and he was out and then
he was on the machine breathing hard and
he opened his eyes and then he tried to
like
like move toward me like lean actually
lean this way and I remember grabbing
grabbing his hand
um and looking through his his uh Soul
those pupils into his soul and um
and being able to communicate with him
and tell them that I love him and I told
him that I'll take it from here as far
as I can go
um
and you did everything right and there's
no no reason to apologize he lived a
great life that's what I told him not
nice and um
that's nice to give somebody that before
they go and um
you know we was there with him and he
kept trying to move and and stuff and
then I felt like
I never felt nothing like this like a
um
you know you feel static with balloons
like a very strong static yeah in my uh
in my hands up to my and it rolls up to
my
elbows like it got hot and it up to my
shoulders
and it was tingling like it was sleep
feeling but then going into a burn
and um
you know I was just present enough to
like feel that
transcend
and then I told the uh I told everybody
he's passing on now I was like I can
feel it
and
um
they rang the nurse and the nurse came
in they was like the machine said he's
still alive and then they just went
like that and I was like he's not as I
was saying I was like he's not they were
checking his body like I could feel him
I can feel him right now going through
me
and he went like right there
and a lot of anger I had at the moment
went with it went went with it good and
um
I had to tell a mother that a child
was going which is hard to do you know
um and then see and then see them out
but it was a very spiritual moment to
have and that was the second time that
happened
um because my grandfather was in a coma
and I showed up and I'm named after him
and my mom was like come say goodbye to
your your granddaddy
and he when I grabbed his hand he came
out of his coma
did he really
coma Whisperer Byron and I realized the
night my dad passed while I'm sitting
there
because my grandfather was 67 when he
died and my dad was 64.
and I was like oh [__] I'm next
[Music]
that's the well you are next I mean even
if you live to be 105 you're still next
because you're the next one and there's
no heirs and I'm named after I'm a third
I'm the Third
do you want children yeah yeah you do
yeah
you better guess what's the party you
could be 60. what's the point what's the
point what's the point of I agree doing
that's what I as that's what I am I told
my girl I ain't trying to like get old
and just eat expensive dinners that [__]
sounds so boring yeah
um
but yeah man
um that was a very very spiritual moment
I'm glad you had that you made it a lot
of people don't get to have that yeah we
made an entire held on and uh
and so much was going so much
Hollywood [__] was going on that it was
a moment of touchdown to have
a real moment and then I left there and
went to back to Toronto to do the Comedy
Festival and it was some of the darkest
hour
that helped probably shape the special
but I actually talked more about the
death and stuff like that yeah
So after talking about all this I told
you before we recorded this your first
time here I wanted to ask you advice you
give to your 16 year old self now after
what we've talked about and the things
you've said here what advice would you
go back and looking on it and give
yourself
that's tough
um
that's a tough thing to do because
everything that happened kind of shaped
and I always follow my instincts
but I would say go bigger
um
and it's all for a reason
it's all for a reason but enjoy it still
enjoy these and the enjoy these moments
and learn how to deal with
be more
present with the the family because just
a lot of skilled relationship skills and
stuff I didn't develop
and I always thought a family were bad
until I was like 21.
yeah
and then wait till you get to be a dad
and then that [__] hits you a different
way yeah I heard you got to relive it
never stops it never stops so then
you're gonna be a grandfather
they got new [__] then you got new [__]
yeah
so
it's funny because when I was when I was
19 I was working a job I didn't like
that everybody thought I should stay it
and I was depressed at that job
um what was it I worked at uh Bell South
was the phone coming oh yeah the time
which is funny I was doing the same job
my dad was doing he worked for the power
company I worked for the thing you know
I mean so I'm like oh this is how you
end up on drugs in a situation like this
but I looked in the mirror
and saw
in a crazy way a 2014 version of myself
like a badass version of myself like a
little like an Entertainer black leather
black glass black hat and he was like
[__] you doing
you bigger than this
and it was it went away that fast so
that's why he said if you can go back in
time it's like I felt the version of
that yeah has already happened you know
and I think we do have those
capabilities to do that spiritually to
ourselves you know
this is a great episode dude thank you
see you
didn't even know what you're going to
talk about you said there you go
um plug everything you want to plug
again the special all of it please Hulu
right now uh go on Hulu if you're in
Australia somewhere it's on Disney plus
spiritual [__] or spiritual n-word is
that really on Disney Plus in with that
title and uh oh you know what
they they just made it spiritual ah
by the time you get the Australia they
just made it spiritual
that you might not
like people might not catch
the they had uh and subtitles they had
[__] because I casually say [__] and
they had [__] and I was like oh you
gotta change that [__] did you tell them
yeah we called it in time because I
called it a friend of mine did a show
and they did it for his and it looked
like two black people being racist to
each other you know what I mean so uh
I'll tell me send me if you're in
Australia or if you're in New Zealand
send me what it sounds like
I wonder if it got like a dude yeah yeah
with their voices over it you know I
doubt it
it's English
yeah but it's like either way check it
out check it out just for the fun of it
you know what I mean
um and then I'm on Instagram
um also uh at Byron bowels
yeah
thank you brother thank you uh as always
ryansickler.com Ryan sickler on all
social media we will talk to you all
next week
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]